mark 7 reading from verse 20. this is
jesus speaking that which cometh out of
the man
that defileth the man
in other words defilement is from within
out not from outside in if you serve the
avenues and you eat pork knowing you
shouldn't eat it
it is not the pork that makes you a
sinner
it's the internal decision to defy god
are you with me so the defilement comes
from within
are you listening to me
you're an advocate you decide to get
drunk
it is not the alcohol that makes you
sinner it is your decision to defy god
the defilement comes from within
that which cometh out of the man that
defile of the man for from within out of
the heart of men precede evil thoughts
adulteries fornications murders death
consciousness wickedness deceit
lasciviousness an evil eye blasphemy
pride foolishness all these evil things
come from within and do what defile the
man defilement is from within